hallöchen freunde und willkommen zu
einer blog vorstellung von einem blog
der in der minecraft version 12 w32 also
in diesem neuen snapshot vorgestellt bzw
hinzugefügt wurde es ist nämlich der
work in progress motto spaß also es ist
der becken bzw bacon irgendwie so also
der wird so geschrieben
so heißt dieser blog auf deutsch
übersetzt leuchtfeuer sage ich den
einfach nur und das erste feature was
ich ganz kurz erwähnen könnte ist dass
dieser block wärme verteilt aber das ist
nicht wichtig sondern das ist so ein
blog da könnt ihr einfach wände auf
einer pyramide steht rechtsklick drauf
machen und dann könnt ihr euch quasi
verzaubern in einem radius von 16
blöcken von diesem block entfernt das
heißt ihr braucht quasi diesen becken
block mit ihr müsst ihr euch aus dem
creative menü inventar auf verschiedene
moment gibt es den hier oben da ist
dieser work in progress mod da könnt ihr
euch den einfach rausziehen und ins
inventar reinholen und dann müsst ihr
den halt auf eine pyramide setzen denn
wenn ich den so irgendwo hinsetzen
passiert damit rein gar nix also der
steht dann einfach nur rum sage ich mal
also ihr müsst ihr dann auf eine
pyramide setzen die entweder aus diamant
blöcken emerald also smaragd blöcken
gold blocken oder eisen blöcken besteht
ihr könnt das auch mission sowie hier
oder einfach aus eisen machen was
eigentlich das einfachste wäre dann habe
ich hier noch ein aus diamanten aus gold
gemacht ihr fragt euch was bringt es
wenn ich größere pyramiden machen das
braucht doch nur das benötigt doch nur
mehr blöcke und zu alle sind es doch nur
blöd nein und zwar wenn ich richtig
drauf machen seht ihr schon hier habe
ich nur geschwindigkeit und eile also
dass sie schneller laufe und sachen
schneller abbauen kann in diesem radius
von diesem blog und das geht nur bei
dieser kleine pyramide also das goldene
hier oben ist dieser becken block und
dieses grüne da sind die blöcke darunter
allerdings wenn ich auf dieser pyramide
bin
seht ihr dass das beides aktiviertes
weil ich auf dieser stufe bin
das heißt infolgedessen wenn ich hier
richtig drauf mache ist das hier
aktiviert und bei der letzten pyramide
ist auch noch dass hier aktiviert also
ich erkläre ich mal ganz kurz was diese
dinge bedeuten und zwar das ist einfach
schneller laufen ihr könnt hier
schneller sachen abbauen damit seit die
resistenz gegen zombies und mops
allgemein hiermit seite könnt ihr höher
springe ich glaube anderthalb locke oder
so und hier mit seid ihr einfach stärker
und können
mops schneller töten also eigentlich
wenn ihr so im normalen mode zeit und
ein mob schlagt und schlagt und
schlagschatten schlagbar braucht ihr
ungefähr acht oder neun schläge so um
den dreh aber wenn ihr das hier halt
aktiviert hat braucht ihr einen oder
zwei glaube ich höchstens regeneration
bedeutet halt einfach draufklicken
regeneriert euch regeneriert sich euer
leben also ganz einfach immer noch kurz
etwas wissenswertes um diesen blog und
zwar diese textur es zurzeit noch eine
art glas textfluss man kann da ein
bisschen durchgucken allerdings wird die
bald schon verändert in der nächsten
version 1.4 dieses ganze läuft links
funktioniert nicht wenn darüber ein blog
ist also dann wird er nicht aktiviert
ich kann das jetzt wieder weg bauen dann
ist er jetzt wieder aktiviert allerdings
funktioniert das nur wenn ihr da glas
darüber setzt also da kann der blogger
durchleuchten
also kann das auch in einem gebäude sein
wo ihr dann einfach oben drüber glasbau
dieses leucht lingens ist genauso hell
wie ein glas ton also als wenn ihr so
als würdet ihr sohn klaus den turm im
himmel bauen das kann ich mal kurz
demonstrieren indem ich das hier mache
moment so ihr seht das leuchtet immer
noch ganz nach oben und es ist echt
extrem hell
ich mach mal wieder kurz auf tag dann
seht ihr schön die sonne aufgehen da ist
naja dieses komplette ding habe ich ja
gar schon gezeigt funktioniert nicht
wenn ihr das hier einfach drauf setzt
sag ich mal
und dieser komplette strahl hier dieser
strahl nach oben dieser große leuchte
strahlt 255 blöcke hoch weil ich weiß
nicht aber warum der so hoch geht keine
ahnung
naja ihr könnt auch dieses leuchtfeuer
mit kolben verschieben also mit bestens
also einfach daran piste setzen dann
wird der verschoben und das läuft alles
und dann funktioniert das
naja jedenfalls zeige ich euch das jetzt
noch mal ganz kurz anhand eines
beispiels er tut einfach mal rein denn
es hat die gleiche wirkung wie ein
diamant smaragde gold machen also ich
kann ich nur empfehlen ein rein zu tun
weil das ist halt der rohstoff an dem
man am leichtesten kommt dann nehmen wir
mal geschwindigkeit klicken einfach auf
fertig und ihr seht wenn ich jetzt er
drücke und ich drücke natürlich er wenn
ich drücke habe ich hier das hier das
ziel runter und geht jetzt wieder hoch
auf 8 sekunden weil wir in einem radius
von 16 blöcken uns befinden wenn wir es
allerdings 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
10 11 12 13 14 15 es wird schon langsam
eng
wenn wir hier rausgehen geht es zwar
immer noch hoch genau jetzt allerdings
wenn ich jetzt ein wenig weiter gehe
seht ihr 4321 und unsere geschwindigkeit
ist weg und mein inventar ist wieder in
der mitte
also wenn ihr erhalt aus diesem ding
raus läuft bleibt ihr nicht mehr und ihr
könnt quasi nicht mehr schneller
sprinten allerdings bin ich jetzt wieder
in diesem radius drin das heißt ich kann
hier dann wieder schneller laufen
also ich könnte jetzt mal ganz kurz ein
bisschen rum ihr seht ihr dann die dass
das funktioniert ihr müsst an diesem
blog kurz abordnung wieder hinsetzen
damit diese wirkung dann quasi weg ist
die zählt jetzt hier noch runter und
dann kann ich auch fertig also dann
jetzt bin ich wieder langsamer und gehen
wir mal zum nächsten und machen das dann
zum beispiel legen gold barren und
sprung verstärkungen okay gut jetzt bin
ich außerdem falsche taste gekommen ich
drücke und das zählt wieder runter und
jetzt ist wieder bei 8 und wenn ich mal
15 drücke seht ihr schon ich kann
deutlich höher springen und naja bin
auch wieder so toll am globalen kann
wieder raus laufen aber das tolle ist
bei diesem blog hier sind es 16 blöcke
in jeder entfernung hier sind es wieder
acht blöcke mehr das heißt 24 bei diesem
sind es 32 also wieder acht mehr und bei
dem jetzt wieder acht mehr als 40 das
heißt wenn ihr euch da irgendwie
verzaubert könnt ihr 40 blog eine
richtung laufen ich kann theoretisch da
auf den berg gehen und das funktioniert
immer noch und zwar geht diese komplette
16 blöcke zum beispiel hier nach oben
nach unten in die erde und links rechts
geradeaus und rückwärts und so war das
immer kurz wieder ab damit ich nicht am
globalen bin also hier könnt ihr dann
einfach ein smaragd ihr zum beispiel
reintun dann bekomme ich stärke fertig
jetzt bin ich gleich am globalen und
zwar rot genau jetzt so jetzt habe ich
wieder stärker alles wie gehabt und zwar
kann ich jetzt einen mob innerhalb von
zwei schlägen strukturierten ohne waffe
mit waffe mit ihren einer waffe dort nur
ein schlag am besten wenn man dann
diamant schwert hat und diese
verzauberung dass das die mobs dann
direkt sterben wenn man auf die zuläuft
dass wir ganz witzig und jetzt bin ich
wieder clean sage ich mal und das hier
möchte ich euch nicht zeigen
hier kann man zwar regeneration und
alles machen das geht auch noch alles
wunderbar wenn ich dann auch drauf
clique aber wenn ich hier ein blogger
ein tour und irgendwas anklicke dann
stützt minecraft ab
das ist nämlich ein bug der dazu
gekommen ist und zwar geht das nur wenn
ganz viele leute vorher nebeneinander
sind das heißt ich habe jetzt hier alle
vier im umkreis geburt wäre diese
pyramide vielleicht da hinten irgendwo
dann wird das vielleicht noch
funktionieren
aber wenn ich mich irgendwie verzaubern
dann stürzten meine minecraft welt ab
das ist mir vorhin schon passiert und
naja
außerdem kann ich euch noch mal kurz was
vorlesen die erweiterung einheit einer
der pyramiden eines aktiven leuchtfeuers
von 505 nach unten auf 5 99 euro kann
auch zu einem crash führen darf weiß ich
nicht ganz genau was sie damit meinten
also dass es eine fünf mal fünf pyramide
und die soll man angeblich dann auf 99
erweitern und schützt es auch ab weiß
ich nicht genau was damit gemeint ist
allerdings ergibt gibt es halt schon ein
paar bugs sage ich mal
allerdings wäre es echt interessant dass
ich euch das mal zeigen könnte weil
darunter und da ist alles auf stufe eins
also geschwindigkeit einer resistenz
sprung verstärkung und stärke
und hier ist alles auf stufe 2 das heißt
wenn ich in diamanten tour und stärke
mit zum beispiel nehme schlag ich nicht
mehr
noch stärker sondern noch noch mehr
stärker und bin noch noch schneller und
alles mögliche
also das ist dann halt alles schon auf
stufe 2 außerdem wie ich schon gesagt
habe die textur oder habe ich da schon
gesagt die textur wird auf jeden fall
bald nochmal verändert werden
wahrscheinlich wird es komplett anders
aussehen als so wie es jetzt gerade
aussieht weil das sieht echt gerade
extremst aus wie glas und ich hab halt
auch schon gezeigt dass wenn man da was
drüber baut einfach nur gras drüber
bauen dann läuft das also das war der
block leuchtfeuer ich wollte ihr euch
einfach mal vorstellen was haltet ihr
von solchen naja vorstellungen sollten
öfters machen als allgemein mod reviews
und solche vorstellungen schreibt unten
in die kommentare
ich würde mich waren daumen hoch freuen
wir uns beim nächsten mal